you know when I was enough when I was a
young man crazy it's not a young man I
worked at a place called All Seasons
rental and I was in charge the propane
tanks I was in charge of strapped them
to the back of the truck and make sure
they don't fall out well one day I
forgot to strap them up and we're going
on the highway and these things were
dropping like flies out the back cars
were dipping and dodging dip dodge dip
dive and dodge dodging and dip and my
brother goes oh my god if one of those
hits the right way it's gonna explode
Wow I got so much trouble didn't you
quietly in so much trouble no carts at
him no one was hurt nothing exploded and
we talked to the guy like the propane
x-ray guys that really worked like that
is these things of Basie bulletproof man
yeah he goes and that's a spark I like
into the tank but even then there's
their safety valves for that he goes
you're fine
it could have killed sone if it bounced
hit the windshield it was as far as
blowing up yours this isn't the movies
you ever want braces or glasses cuz your
other friends had him you know but I
faked like that bad very common I think
like I had bad vision because my brother
had horrible vision like horrible vision
he looked like to get off the Sandlot
and the one that goes for a burn and so
we went to LensCrafters and I was a damn
those are cool glasses jaws are you so I
was like what's that say my dad's like
you can't really so then they they
brought me in the back and I think like
got read and he's like what's that
lowest one say and I was like I'll act
and then I'd like mess up the last dude
he's like he can definitely see he's
making this up I just want him cuz they
was I don't know my boy years he wanted
to be so young man you want to be smart
brother Adam I did would would do
weirder things like that I would go I'm
I would like decide that my name was
Alex because I think you're insane yep
so you tell friends you do didn't people
like me my name is Alex I wanted to be
Alex for the day what a [ __ ] weirdo
but I was young I was like thirty when
did you first start lying about your age
I never have lied about my age actually
you've never even you're like 40 you
look younger you know I'm saying yeah I
never did because maybe cuz of Google
but I never did it I did it like the
like just a few months ago not like I
just caught myself some girls a calorie
I was like 31 no and I went in my brain
oh wow no you know that I just lied
about my age yeah she's gonna go home
and if she wants me up he's definitely
see Rena z0i I don't mean to talk about
this but Steve Rannazzisi was talking
about that like when he got you know he
would talked about being in the towers
nice to sit them but he said he goes he
kind of said it to a guy that he didn't
know he was new and he was standing
there and a guy goes bro he was in the
towers and he wasn't and and and he was
like he goes I have a why of five
seconds right now to just tell this guy
no no then they were all like oh really
and then he was like yeah and then
Austin became the tower guy but he was
like now if I tell him I'm lying they're
gonna think I'm the biggest weirdo and I
just want to make friends I'm here at
the college during the whole thing so he
kind of like goes like alright and then
from then on he became the guy in the
child yeah yeah yeah and then he had to
live that forever sometimes when I say
something whether it's on a podcast or
we're on stage like there's there's a
little thing in my head that goes hey
here's the thing if I had to kill my own
[ __ ] food I'd just be vegetarian it's
too hard yeah that's fair you know you
know I mean much work it's like yeah
you're not a hunter this is too hard
I just eat all the plants you know Brian
remember Kennedy and I date Brian I did
a show with Bert Kreischer his cooking
show this is burnt soms but I love Burke
right the [ __ ] love as my favorite
people on earth shame we had to kill
crabs I can do it right do it
Brian sociopath I know I killed I
literally could not do it I was like and
I'm not saying people shouldn't do it no
because I eat crab yeah I'm not saying
people shouldn't do it you shoot your
food eat it uh I'll just rinse plants
don't run I grab them and eat them
yeah I'm with Chris on this all day I'll
just be careful there that's why you I
would go hunt and you would stay behind
and you would mash
no dude I'll tell you what I would do
you know I would be doing mash then I
would go raw water from the well no and
you'd have you would go out you would go
unpaired how about this you present me
with it what about this yeah big there'd
be a big welcoming back party you'd have
a dress Onkel hi Danny
that's actually not what will be
happening you know will be happening
while you're out hunting I would be up
in your girl's guts oh wow about that Oh
home by leaving it in Oh leaving my guy
and guess what and making me raise your
raise my kid
Wow clothing wise your look like oh
alright well your car that's you in
three years okay yeah okay
anyway I'm your dad more so after the
Luke Rockhold
Yoel Romero fight I guess Romero came up
to him right away
tried to kiss him you know like in a
kind gesture Kissel felt he was not
there he was out of it you know you have
no idea what happened yeah so Bisbing
was saying on his podcast the believe
you me podcast he's like dude he just
got knocked out he's devastated why is
he going up there the officials should
have stopped it from happening
yeah those officials I don't think
they're used to this high level of
fights and they've never really dealt
with stuff like this they have to catch
up a little bit they did their best I
get it but yeah I agree with Mike on
this where you just gotta you gotta give
him time especially guys knocked out
really no one should be around it's even
tough for corn and get in there
typically in the u.s. when a guy gets
knocked out cuz medics are in there and
you know thought so yeah so I don't know
but officer you're real it's not that
Tom Brady and his son quit kiss them on
the lips are you doing